so the last part of this workshop
is our encoding showcase
where uh we are going to have several
people
starting with catalin telling us about
interesting stories about interest and
encodings
uh so probably to save time i
let people introduce themselves as they
prefer
so please let alone thank you uh so my
name is kotlin fosakosh and i
prepared here a few slides on our work
with
uh mark wuzzin army embira and sophie
parag
and we published this work last year at
the cpa ior conference
and basically our goal was in that work
to find
assault encoding for sequence at most
one constraints
and i just hope that you will find
interesting
or steps so i would start just really
quickly
uh by showing how these constraints look
like
if we uh assume that we have a sequence
of
let's say 15 boolean variables and we
define
a bit of five then the sequence at post
one
constraint set in that configuration uh
would be the conjunction of these 11
atmosphere constraints where we can see
that each of the constraints are talking
about exactly five of the variables
and the easiest to imagine these
constraints by if you
have a window of bit five and you slide
it through
your sequence of variables and in each
step you say that all the variables
which are right now in the window
among them at most one can be true
now we originally call these constraint
sets staircase at most one constraints
because if you realign them by the
variables then you can get this really
nice
shape of the stairs but
in this talk i will try to always call
them sequence constraints because this
is how
they were apparently introduced in the
cp community
like several decades ago
but it's important that there it usually
means a more general global constraint
while in our work we were really
focusing just on this sub
case where we talk about atmosphere
constraints
and the reason why we wanted to encode
these problems as
sad because we wanted to solve the
anti-bandwidth problem with the help of
subservers which is basically a graph
labeling max mean optimization problem
and
unfortunately i do not have the time to
properly introduce it but
in our paper you can find how encoding
of this problem
leads for several sequence constraints
so if we have this constraint set
uh we basically would like to find the
truth assignment for each of the boolean
variables in it
such that all the constraints are
satisfied and
of course this is only one constraint in
a bigger problem so we have much more
constraints on the same variables
and a straightforward solution for that
problem would be
just to simply use an of the shaft at
most one
encoding for each of the constraints
like in thought we have several uh these
kind of methods
and uh so this is uh how we tried at the
very beginning and uh soon we realized
that the resulting formulas are just
extremely large so on that figure you
can see if we have for example 500
boolean variables
then depending on the width of this
window which i mentioned
we can easily end up with more than
hundred thousands of closes
and again this is just one of four many
constraints in the problem
so um here on that figure for example
this red line
is the sequential uh counter encoding
or this dark red colored line
is the pairwise naive encoding of each
of the atmosphere
constraints and apparently this is the
smallest what we can get up to
a certain bit and already here we get
this size just by filtering out
repetitions of
uh pair constraints because uh
if you take a closer look on the
constraints we can see that
they are continuously overlapping so
there is a really large level of
synthetic
sharing between the atmosphere and
constraints and that was exactly what
was motivating us
for looking for other encodings where we
couldn't
somehow exploit this sharing or
overlapping
between the constraints so
in our approach we first
try to focus on the disjoint constraints
in this constraint set so we picked uh
every fifth
constraint if we stay with this example
where then we will have uh for each
variable
each variable will occur in only one of
the atmosphere constraints
and all the variables will be in at
least one of the constraints so it's
maybe easier if you put these selected
window constraints next to each other
that basically we cover the whole
sequence of variables
with these selected constraints
and as a very first step we just simply
built a binary decision diagram for each
of these selected
atmosphere constraints for this we used
a method which was introduced for
pseudo-boolean constraints in 2012.
and one observation in this building
step that
the order of the decision variables in
this bdd
is basically implicitly determines how
do we evaluate
the sum on the left hand side of the
constraint so it's basically the
associativity of the audition
so in the very first step we constructed
this bdd for each of our
selected window constraint and as a
second step we continued and
now built another bdd for the exact same
constraints
and it sounds pretty wasteful that why
would we encode once again something
which we included
just in the previous step but a big
difference is that
in that step we choose the exact
opposite of the variable orderings
so if in the first step the bdd was
reading the sum from the left to the
right then in the second step we
read it now from the right to the left
and that's exactly why we actually
recorded encoding duplex encoding
because we
encode the constraints twice
and uh so at that point we have two bdds
for each of our selected
disjoint at most one constraints and
then we just
simply traverse these bdds and
trans transform them into cnf form for
this again there are already several
methods in the literature you can pick
your favorite one but
uh what is an important side effect of
that step is that uh for each
subtree in these bdds then we will have
a boolean variable which
basically refers on that part of the
constraint
and that's exactly what we need in the
last step
where we start to focus on on all the
other constraints which we did not
encode in that step so the overlapping
ones
because for these constraints we just
apply a simple
uh decomposition where we just split
them up into
two parts and for example here we have
an atmosphere
uh constraint from x8 till x12 and we
say that okay there is one part of it
which must
fulfill the atmosphere constraint and
there is another part
and uh also we have to guarantee that at
least one of the two parts
uh must be at most zero so this is just
a very long way to say that
the sum of these five variables can't be
more than one
but by using this long phase
description we actually use only
expressions which already occur
in our previously built pdds where we
already introduced boolean variables to
refer on these
expressions so actually we can encode
this
at most one constraint only by three
clauses
two units and one binary clause and uh
that's actually the strength of the
encoding that uh this the number of
clauses here is completely independent
from the length of the
atmosphere constraints because even if
the width of the window would be 200 we
would still need only three closes
to describe it
so these are the four steps of the
encoding
uh if we put all of it together then we
can see that we selected this disjoint
at most one constraints we built two
bdds for each of them
then they encoded them into a
conjunctive normal form
and then for all the remaining
constraints we just introduced three
clauses to glue together the right parts
of the
bddds and as a result of this encoding
now if we come back to the size
comparison
then we can see that we end up indeed
with a very very small
representation of the problem compared
to any of the off-the-shelf
start encodings uh but
on its own it does not guarantee that
the solver will like
this formula uh so we also try to use
this encoding then to address the
anti-bandwidth problem
and here you can see first just a few
smaller graphs as i said it's an
optimization problem
and for graphs so here we have the
nodes and edges of the graphs and we
compared four different approaches
uh to find the optimal anti-bandwidth
so there was our start encoding um there
was the state of the art which was a
mip formalization of the problem and
iterative mip formalization
and additionally we considered two cp
formalizations but both of them were
really naive encoding of the problem
ones with c plex and once with
[Music]
thing and already uh um yeah so in these
columns we can see the best found
solution for each of the
approaches and already on these uh
smaller graphs we can see that the sat
approach could find actually the best
solutions in almost all of the cases
and the difference becomes uh on the use
if we move on to the larger graphs
because
here we can see that the naive cp
approach could not scale at
all and why the need formalization could
solve
could at least start to solve some of
the problems in most of these cases our
approach could find a better solution
so just to sum it up with one sentence
the main
steps of our encoding is that we
encode some of these constraints twice
with the hope that then we can maximize
the structural sharing
when it's about the other constraints
and
as a result we got a really short
encoding for
uh sequence atmosphere constraints and
uh this is actually in some cases even
smaller than the
cp approach and here i had another point
about the our consistency of this
encoding which i will now
leave out and yeah then we use this
encoding to address the anti-bandwidth
problem and we found some nice
solutions so that was what i wanted to
show you and uh
thank you very much for your attention
thank you so much so what was the point
about the r consistency
uh that depending on what cnf encoding
we use on the bdds but in general this
unit propagation establishes
our consistency but now i'm not sure if
it means the same for me
as it means in the previous uh
discussion so um
i rather would not go there okay thank
you
questions comments this is really cool
thank you
okay if there are no questions let's
move on so aside please
share your screen and
uh yeah sure let me share my screen
okay um
can you see my screen uh yeah with
everything on it
oh sure
okay
great should i go uh yes please okay
so my name is said najati i'm with aws
at the moment but this work was
uh done during my phd with um professor
vijay ganesh at university of waterloo
and it's about uh doing crypt analysis
on cryptographic hash functions
using sat technology
so the problem that we wanted to look at
was the algebraic fault attacks on
specifically sha-1 hash functions and
uh the question is um given a hash
output
and some extra constraint that we could
extract from
injecting fault on onto a hardware
implementation of the hash function
uh find uh a message that hashes to that
output
but i don't go into all the details of
algebraic fault
i just want to focus on the core problem
within that
algebraic fault attack which is the
pre-image attack
and simply stated given a hash
output you need to find an x
which hashes to that particular output
and the way we usually encode this
problem into sand is just
encode the sha-1 hash function in cnf
and then fix the output according to the
value of
h and solve the problem for x
to be able to encode the sha-1 hash
function in cnf
we need to look inside the shelves and
show one
and see how it looks like so this is the
architecture of a step function inside
sha-1 it operates on a bunch of state
variables a
i's on the left and
it mixes in the values of these state
variables
passes through some boolean functions
and mixes in
chunks of input which are 32-bit chunks
of input
and after that it generates the next
intermediate or
state variable and it goes on mixing and
different chunks of input to arrive at
the output
from these state variables and all of
these
state variables chunks of input these
constants
all of them are 32-bit registers and all
of these functions are 32-bit uh bit
vector functions
here f is a boolean bitwise function and
these plus boxes
are modular additions these um
thingies are bitwise rotations
so they don't change the bits they just
reorder the bits
inside the register
and shavon actually repeatedly applies
this function
on the inputs and uh state variables
to arrive at a hash digest at the end
uh so to also
did the f function in uh in the middle
it could change based on the step that
we are in
for the first 20 steps the box is an
if function so it simply says
um if x then y else z
for the next 20 steps the function f is
3 input xor and for the after that we
use the majority
3 input majority and the rest is
again xor and i should mention that
sha-1 does this 80 times but it's
eight solving for 80 steps is so hard
that we solved a round reduced version
like more than like 23
22 steps instead of 80 steps
and now if we want to encode this
function into uh
cnf we need to encode basic blocks in
cnf and then
connect all of these together via
encoding of a circuit into sat for
example
um simply to encode the if function
uh because it's a bitwise function for
each of the i
um output bits of function f
we say that we force it to be equivalent
to the
application of function f on the inputs
and
we derive the cnf formulation of this
equivalence similarly we could do this
for xor function
and majority function and
arrive at these cnn formulas and concat
all of these together to generate
formulas for
different steps uh
but these are the like easier ones uh
the
more complicated one is implementing the
modular edition and why is it more
complicated because it's a
there are five things that are being
added together
these elements to arrive at the next
intermediate value so one way to encode
this
is simply to encode a two operand
edition
two operand 32-bit wide adder
and then add two of these then the
result with the next one result with the
next one and so on
but this gives you a very large encoding
uh
overall and it would be harder for a
satellite to solve
another approach is to just encode
directly modular
multi-brand addition so in this scheme
you could see that for example
we have five different
bit vectors of x y z
uh t and w and uh
in each column we sum them up and
find the sum and carry value so if we
sum up these five values there are five
bits
it is a bit it gives us a value between
zero and five so it's
small at most three bits which means
that we have a sum bit
and we have uh two carry bits that you
carry to the next levels
and then uh if you
look at the uh so it means that
each position receives at most
two carry values because it could get a
carry value from the previous column
or the two previous columns but at the
end of the day
it becomes uh summing up seven values
and uh still seven
bits some sums up to seven which is one
one one
uh it means that it doesn't exceed
generating two carries
so one way to summing up this uh
like implementing this multiple brand
edition is that if we have a circuit
to compute this uh seven to three
counter which uh accepts as input
seven uh bits with the same weight and
generate a three bit
value that represents how many ones are
in those seven bits
then we could column by column sum up
everything and chain all of these via
carry
signals and in 2012
nosom in his work um
implemented this seven to three counter
value
using uh espresso logic minimizer
uh logic optimizer sorry so it gave
the truth table of this 723
counter into espresso and got
an encoding of how to implement this
function
instead of making it uh by hand so
espresso gave
a very compact encoding in terms of
not generating any auxiliary variables
so it directly generated a bunch of
clauses that
produces the output
so in our work uh we did an observ
um interesting observation i was looking
into
seeing if i use no sums encoding
and if i set all of the bits
at the input of a hash function how many
propagations
the solver will do to arrive at the
output bits
and surprisingly i saw that when i set
all of the input bits and give it to a
stat solver
actually sat solver cannot derive all of
the output bits only with unit
propagation
so the information from the inputs of
the function does not
flow using unit propagation to the
outputs of the function
and from the csp uh literature
and karen's talk we know that
uh um this has a name and
this is studied very well and it means
that the no sums encoding is not are
consistent
because there exists an implication
at the higher level in the cp like
constraint definition
level uh that the unit propagation on
this part
particular encoding cannot propagate so
it's not our consistent
and here i could give a quick example if
i have time
you have one minute or so
oh okay so i could skip through the
example
uh and mentioned that generally
there's this ten so for our work there
was this tension of
uh having this small sized encoding
and having an encoding that is good for
propagation this is exactly what
karen was also talking about
so ideal is to have a small encoding
that has
good propagation like good
uh but our approach was that to keep
like keep this small encoding the
compact encoding that works very well
with the sat solver
but solve the deficiency of the unit
propagation
by extending the propagation
programmatically
so we use the programmatic sat
architecture which is
inspired by cdclt paradigm
and what it does is that the propagation
callback analyzes the partial assignment
and sees if there's anything set
that implies something but that
implication was
missed by unit propagation and then at
that point
the um propagation callback will
return the reason clause back to the
unit propagation
and unit helps unit propagation
strengthens
it uh to actually imply the missed
literal
so in other words we could say that all
of these constraints that we're
implementing inside the propagation
callback is a bunch of constraints that
are implemented in c language for
example
because the sat solver is our solver is
written in c
and we could say that we went uh
to generate an encoding which is a mix
of cnf and c
and this is the overall architecture of
very exactly diplomatic programmatic
um units lion
and in our work we extended both of the
propagation
and conflict analysis but in this talk
we're more concerned about the
programmatic propagation and the
architectural it means that after unit
propagation if there's no conflict
uh programmatic propagation checks if
there's any missing
literal and uh if so it
generates a reason clause and uh gives
it back to his propagation and
there's a tight loop between these two
uh also i need to mention that we uh
focused on the relations uh on the input
bits and output bits
chunks of none are consistent part which
is mostly the
multi-operand addition combined with the
rotations of the inputs
and uh so because generalized art
consistency are consistent is a very
strong
uh property we're not
enforcing it on all of the intermediate
and auxiliary variables
but we're enforcing it on the
multi-operand edition part
that is this main source of being not
are consistent
uh inside the xiaohuan encoding so we
kind of repair the
broken chain from the input to the
output
uh so we could kind of
called it input output or consistent
and in some papers it is called
propagation complete
which means that if you have a boolean
function and you set something in the
input of the bullet function it should
propagate to the output
or is it it will go a little faster
yes this is my last slide so uh we
implemented this in maple set
and this is the vanilla maple sat on the
left
and uh the application of only
uh programmatic propagation gave us this
uh big boost on algebraic voltage
instances thank you
thank you so much say so uh let's
probably for the sake of
time move questions to the end because
otherwise we are going to lose the
audience sorry for that unless somebody
has a quick
really immediate question while stefan
is
setting up
it's a this is very interesting that you
could get
those non-art consistent encoding social
and things don't propagate that's kind
of funny
okay so let's move on and
uh for the sake of time stefan
please the floor is all yours
thank you i would like to talk about
an approach where we have now actually a
few papers
with all these co-authors where we
try out this approach on various
problems
so the initial motivation was this when
i started working on satin coatings a
couple of years ago
it was a bit frustrating because all
these nice
instances uh from big data et cetera are
quite large and when you start with a
satin coating
typically a satin coating is polynomial
but for some of this more
complicated problems the polynomial is
of order three or four
and even if the subserver can deal with
millions of variables which is
in clauses which is always which are
great and
still when you first have this end to
the
three or n to the four blow up then
the actual instant size you can deal
with is
quite reduced so there's quickly that
if it's a graph problem uh with 60
to up to 100 notes you can do it but
then
it's getting really tough and
um and therefore we
had a couple of years ago this idea
for this we now call it slim satbis
local improvement method
we try to overcome this limit that we
apply
the encoding the satin coding or now we
also
do it with smug salt encodings to small
parts of some initial solution
that uh was computed by some heuristics
and then we use the satin coating to
improve this in
this solution locally and we if it's in
a loop
and we improve improve improve
and often we just do it as long as we
have time
yes the slim is also somehow related to
the large neighborhood
search meter heuristic but if you really
look at applications of lns
they look quite differently to what we
do with slim so
on a high scale there might be some
connection between these two methods
but i would not i don't don't see this
connection
really in in the individual applications
and here uh that's it that's the this
graphic of the slim loop
so the heuristic that we call the global
solver
provides us the initial solution and
then
the local solver which is of msat and
maxsat
uses this initial solution to improve it
over and over
and maybe there are a few there's a bit
of terminology
maybe let me just focus on the budget
that we call like the the size of the
local part
that we can work with so for a graph
problem
the local budget would be something like
about
50 or so 50 nodes of the
graph that we can deal in the saturn
coding but it it
varies and the local timeout that's the
time
we allow this sat server or max
outsolver to solve this
local instance there it sometimes turns
out to be
not really good to give to bring the
budget up to the limit
and also this local dime out sometimes
it turns out it's better to keep this
value smaller than what we could
actually do and overall it still
outperforms
an approach where we have larger budgets
and
larger local timeouts and these are
so far these five problems that we
solved with
with the slim approach and
that's um the the first three uh
problems are to compute certain
decomposition for graphs
so branch widths three widths and three
depths
uh for all three um one must say also
all share this general idea of uh slim
for each individual problem one needs to
um
[Music]
to solve certain problems because it's
one has to fit in
the the new solution to the local
problem to that global solution
and that this works one has to um
solve some things uh specific to the
problem at hand so there's no like
general black boxing where you can just
throw your problem on and
and slim will solve it um and
i will together with with vedanta we
will talk a little bit about
the last one the basic network structure
learning
problem and later um andre will talk
about
um using slim to compute decision trees
uh of low depth um
and yeah just briefly what is this
this problem so if we start at the right
hand side
we want to find a basin network
which is basically a deck a directed
acyclic graph
where we also the nodes are also labeled
with some tables but we are interested
in this structure in this deck
and we want to find such a deck using
um a score function well basically for
every node we have
a potential parent sets
um each parent set gives us a different
score
and the optimization problem is finding
a deck
on these notes such that the sum
of all these scores are maximized
and so we have an end in addition
because
later on we wanted to do basin reasoning
probabilistic reasoning on this
basic network we want that this basic
network has load 3 bits
so we want to optimize the score
subject to a certain bound on the three
bits
and so in other words we in maxsat we
will have hard clauses for
cyclicity it should be a deck and
bounded three bits
using a certain encoding for these two
things
and it's actually partial magsat as
maria luisa
already introduced because we also have
now soft clauses
and these soft clauses represent the
scores of this
uh different parent sets and by
optimizing
uh the the sum of uh
of the weights of these clauses we can
optimize
um the overall score and now
um i have a little
kind of animation i'm happy to that i
can show it we
produced it for the triple ai poster
session
and yeah there were not so many people
around so i'm happy that i can
share it once more but it's very quick
so assume this is the 3d composition
we get from the local solver
so it's heuristically computed based
network and this is the 3d composition
of it
now with a certain strategy we select
a subtree so that we keep within our
budget
and then we form a local instance so we
basically collect all the nodes of the
the probabilistic variables that appear
in this chosen
local network and now the aim is to find
a new
network for this red part and fit it
back to the
to the other parts however that this
works we
need to make sure that these things will
fit together
therefore we take from this boundary
back certain
edges and um give the local instance
additional
virtual edges that this local instance
will need to cover
and the other thing is we want to
maintain acyclicity
if this new local solution is acyclic
it could still become cyclic by some
directed path that's run
through this gray external trees
so therefore we look for directed cycles
in this external trees and if there is
such a directed
on the directed cycles directed bath if
there is such a path
then we can represent this by
call it a virtual arc which gives us an
additional constraint
the the local the local solution needs
to specify
now if we put all these things together
virtual edges virtual arcs
we now get to this local instance which
is
more constrained than a general basic
network structure learning
instance and now we can feed this into
with our maxsat encoding to our max
subsolver
which produces a new instance
this green one and because of this
vertical
edges this then fits
together with the with this
subtrees that we put aside and because
of this
virtual arcs we can be sure that this
solution
will be acyclic and
now we repeat this selection until we
come up with until we run out of time so
basically we can go on and on
theoretical there could be a limit where
no additional improvement is
not is not possible anymore but in
practice you could go on
for hours and you will always be able to
improve
and it turns out that the speed of
improvement
is better than the speed of improvement
when we apply this heuristics and
run the heuristics for longer but here i
hand over to vaidhanathan who will now
talk a little you have about one minute
left
one minute left okay i think um
uh please
continue right now yeah so i'll
quickly go over the uh am i audible
yes uh can people hear me
yeah sorry okay yeah so i'll quickly go
over the experimental evaluation and
what we learned from this
so basically these um for our
experimental setup we
started with an initial solution that we
got from this heuristic after 30 minutes
and at this point we split into two
parts and we
run slim over the solution to obtain
solution b
and we continue running the heuristic
over the solution to obtain solution a
and comparing uh these two solutions by
um the bic score metric we really we saw
that the
slim solutions are significantly
outperformed the
heuristic solutions and what was worth
noting here is that
with small budget values of 10 and small
timeout values of two seconds
we were able to maximize the performance
and
our intuition is that we are able to get
in multiple
uh runs of this local improvement and
that
that matters more than getting more uh
better quality runs so in this case
quantity dominates quality
um so this again is a quick plot of how
with the smaller timeouts you can see
that there's more improvements and the
quality of improvements doesn't change
that much between the different timeouts
and
on the right you can see a cdf plot of
k max plus slim which is running slim on
top of kmax versus
just running kmax alone and the
slim version is significantly uh
better at improving instances than just
continuing to run kmax after
this 30 minute mark and one last thing
that i'd like to point out is
which we found really interesting was
that um in many cases this slim
version of the encoding which is
iteratively running
over local parts uh to obtain the
solution
was also much better than the one short
version
which is in cases where the global
instance is small enough to be
encoded and solved practically
by just a single sight encoding the slim
version was
much better and um
the only problem only drawback here
being that we have no
guarantee of optimality and apart from
that we realize that
um the performance of the slim version
is much better because it's able to
break up the
problem into individual chunks and
really focus on these smaller local
chunks so this is what we learned from
our experiments with slim
and andre will continue with a different
problem and a different perspective
so thank you thank you so much and uh
please under uh stephanie if you
wouldn't
mind stopping sharing if andre is doing
his own basically just
say one thing uh those are very short
talking
and there is not enough time for to do
justice to anything of it
but my hope was that this would allow
you to
see a sneak view of what kind of cool
results people did
and maybe we could get together and
arrange
longer talks by the same people kind of
more directly and interactive
rather than through workshops okay andre
please um
maybe just yeah i will go briefly but
for 10 seconds i
might want to make some advertisement
for the seminar so if any of the
short talks interested you write me so
then we can set up in similar talk
uh in the future so since we're it's
really late that we'll keep this
short and i hope that uh stefan and
vaidyanathan already
convinced you that that sat based local
improvement is is a good technique and
we applied it to decision tree learning
and we were able to
to greatly improve upon existing
decision tree heuristics
um but what i want to
highlight in in the story is um there
was there were
there was a state-of-the-art encoding
for decision trees that performed best
among
those that were proposed and there they
assumed
a decision tree so maybe um briefly
so we tried to to optimize the depth of
decision trees
get deaf minimal decision trees and the
best encoding
uh that was known when when we started
this was
um and according to assumed a full
binary tree with a given depth so if you
have
def d the binary tree has two to the
d many nodes and this is a
and since you have to reference every
node in the encoding this is
exponential in the depth and we proposed
a new encoding
that was based on a different
characterization of decision trees on a
partition based characterization
and this encoding was linear in the
depth but quadratic in a number of
samples and usually you have
a way greater number of samples than the
dev so in
general case our encoding was slower
than the state-of-the-art encoding
but there were edge cases where our
encoding was faster so what we did is
we try to find the limits for both
encodings in terms of the number of
samples in the in the instance and the
the maximum depth
and then we use this these limits when
we selected our sub instances
so that we stay within the capabilities
of the two encodings
and you also determined um the the kind
of the threshold values when
when does which encoding perform best so
which are kind of the edge cases for
which our encoding performs better
then we created a hybrid encoding that
chooses which of the two encodings to
use based on this data so how
deep is the tree that we try to optimize
and how about
how many samples do we have and um
so the result is that if we use this
hybrid encoding we can decrease the
depth by
35 34 on average compared to using only
one encoding
and since the the instances we used vary
greatly in the size
and in the depth of the tweet this means
that the gains are
vastly larger for for many instances and
very slow
very little for for other instances and
slim worked generally very well on the
on the
on on this problem so we were able to
improve almost all the instances
so my take away from this is that it's
even if you have multiple encodings and
there is a clear best encoding it may
pay off to look into
the edge cases for which other of other
encodings may perform better and then if
you can statically
choose uh use with multiple encodings
and the second
story i want to briefly mention uh is so
this is a an ongoing workshop will be a
little bit more abstract
but basically we have it's a graphic
decomposition encoding we've worked on
and it's based on illumination ordering
so you have a linear ordering
and you eliminate nodes according to
this ordering
where elimination is defined by the
problem at hand and usually you do this
in in in an implicit way yeah so in code
which note uh be eliminated before each
other node but you don't encode
this is the first notice the second node
is the third node because
using this implicit method you can use
only take two out of n
as varian is the number of nodes many
variables and you only need
constraints for transitivity but our
encoding ended up to use
a number of nodes to the fourth many
clauses
then we thought a little bit more about
it and then we found out if in this case
if we encode the ordering implicit
explicitly
so we really encode this is the first
note to be eliminated this is the second
one and so on
we can do this in cubicly many clauses
and this introduces some symmetries that
are not existent in the first encoding
and the ordering part is a bit larger
but then the checking constraints
are we need fewer checking constraints
and
how big is the difference so on a graph
of 75 notes which was the biggest
instance that could be solved by first
encoding
the um it requires 30 million clauses
and 2.5 million variables and takes
about two hours to solve
and the second encoding takes only 2.5
million clauses and 0.3 million value
boost but it's not able to solve the
instance optimally within eight hours
and even on the smaller instance with
only 15 nodes the second encoding fails
so it's not news that investing some
some size into
uh symmetry breaking pays off usually
but for me the extent of this like 30
million compared to 2.5 million
is a huge gap was very surprising and i
thought that may be an interesting
story to share for this talk so with
this um
done thank you so much
and thank you everybody for the
wonderful story sorry for running over
time
uh other quick questions or should we
take it to gather town
or maybe i'll post the link to gather
town in meantime
if anybody has questions i have a short
one
could one use slim to re-encode a cna
formula such that
model counting would become easier
or did they misunderstand something
stefan
i have no immediate thoughts on that i
would have to think about this
the question once more uh whether we can
do what
i couldn't take a cnn formula and use
slim on it
such that the motor counting would
become easier
so the trees should become slower
smaller now yes yes that you can you can
do yes
um actually we are also working on
something uh
because the three bits is not if you
have not only binary variables
in your basic network then
it three bits is a bit of a very coarse
measurement because it matters whether
you have a binary variable or a variable
of domain size
10 and so on could formulate a more
more fine-grained measurement
than three bits and uh we have already
some preliminary
um results that with slim we can quite
easily
encode such uh constraints and
so it is quite versatile to apply a slim
uh in this setting okay but
you would not usually start from the cnf
or
doesn't
produced by the heuristics because
we are working here with with about up
to 4 000
probabilistic variables so it's a huge
instance
and there are heuristics who give us
within seconds
uh a heuristically computed
basic network and then flim
starts selecting
sub networks and improving the score
there without
worsening the three respond okay
thank you
okay any more questions comment this was
such a great session thank you
so much everybody who spoken everybody
who asked questions
uh if not
then let's call it a workshop and see
you at gather town
thank you so much